there's so much disinformation going
around you're probably getting it at
this moment on your text we certainly
are we haven't faced a medical crisis
like this in living memory we know that
coronavirus constitutes a major threat
to the country of course it does well we
really don't have a clear picture of
right now is what's coming next so we
spent the weekend talking to some of the
smartest people we know in medicine in
business and in politics everyone had
strong opinions needless to say but what
was striking was that there was no clear
consensus on how the country should
respond to this all decent informed
people but completely different points
of view that should not surprise you
people of good faith are working toward
a couple of different goals tonight
which at times collide with one another
our first obligation everyone agrees is
to keep our people safe if we can
prevent Americans from getting their
coronavirus we should do that at the
same time though we need to protect our
economy and that is not just something
that Wall Street cares about to be
totally clear economic decline is
dangerous for everyone especially at the
bottom of the economy it's a legitimate
human concern it's not just financial
it's about families here's the problem
we've got two imperatives and they often
conflict so if you ask an epidemiologist
what we ought to do next the answer is
simple shut it down close every public
space until the virus passes hospitals
would get a pass of course but
restaurants bars hotels movie theaters
Airlines everything from a public health
standpoint that makes sense but what
would be the consequences of doing that
millions and millions of people would
lose their jobs some of them for good
we'd enter a severe recession with mass
unemployment and it could get worse from
there it's not a joke that could happen
you would see an awful lot of people in
poverty in middle America and that poses
its own kind of public health risk poor
countries are never healthy countries if
you want great health care you've got to
pay for it and you have to have money to
do so so you see the problem responding
to this epidemic requires balance it
does it's a complex question and the
deeper into it you dig the more
convinced too that you will become the
answers are not obvious
don't let anyone lie to you about that
and of course they are you'll hear
people claim they've got a simple answer
that will fix everything
ignore those people Only Fools pretend
they can see the
wise people admit uncertainty that's the
hallmark of wisdom as a tonight here's
what we do know first we're only at the
beginning of all of this we're pretty
certain of that dr. Anthony foul she
said as much over the weekend as I've
said many times and I repeated the worst
is yes ahead for us it is how we respond
to that challenge that's going to
determine what the ultimate end point is
going to be so shutdowns and travel
restrictions which are increasingly in
place will help slow the spread but they
are not enough they're not a big enough
response for what's coming the New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo is now asking the
administration to muster the military to
fight the virus the coming crisis is
where over overwhelming our health care
system that is going to happen that
curve is a wave and it's gonna break on
the hospital system we need additional
beds and we need the Army Corps of
Engineers to come in here and retrofit
state buildings dormitories etcetera
start now bring in that Army Corps of
Engineers this is what they do they
build at a press conference today the
president said the administration is
strongly considering Governor Cuomo's
request and it seems like they are and
of course there are other ways we could
use the military's expertise and
manpower it has a lot of both if things
get bad we will need more ventilators
than we currently have we may need more
breathing masks too in Italy the
military has been mobilized in an effort
to quadruple production at that
country's lone ventilator manufacturer
in South Korea the military is assisting
in mass production that's what they're
doing we have the most sophisticated
Armed Forces on earth and the best
funded no doubt there are many other
ways they could help use your
imagination they have helped so many
other nations in crisis around the world
and of course they want to their
Americans and then there's our second
priority keeping our economy stable now
once again this is not the same as using
monetary policy to prop up the stock
market Washington in case you haven't
noticed has become convinced that the
Federal Reserve is the only available
instrument for managing our economy
that's not only unimaginative and
small-minded though it is it's dangerous
how much cheap money can we print
for the public loses faith in the system
and inflation explodes economists in
Washington seem to think that'll never
happen we can do this forever but we
can't and they know we can't on some
level at some point we will become
zimbabwe and you don't want that and by
the way it's missing the point anyway
the real imperative right now is saving
jobs for government bureaucrats and
university administrators and corporate
HR directors talk show hosts actually a
month out of the office constitutes a
kind of vacation but for the classes
below it could be the beginning of a
long spiral a real one waiters
bartenders retail workers huge parts of
the service industry on which we are
dependent massive part of our economy
could see their income dropped to zero
and not come back Kevin Hassett the
former chairman of the President's
Council of Economic Advisers just warned
that a million jobs could vanish in the
month of April a million people suddenly
without jobs that's the nightmare
scenario countries with high
unemployment are desperate countries and
more ominous they are unstable countries
always you don't want that some of the
professional class have suggested a
guaranteed basic income as a response to
this threat Mitt Romney has suggested
sending every American a monthly check
for $1,000 that's likely a well-meaning
idea a lot of smart people are behind it
but it's also decadent and foolish name
a place that's become happier and more
prosperous under a scheme like that
Indian reservations the inner-city rural
areas where half the male population
gets monthly disability checks or for
that matter if we're being honest how
many happily idle inherited money people
do you know rich people
none they're all drunk of course they
are people need to work they want to
work work gives them meaning and purpose
and dignity that's not some hollow
slogan it's true it's true in your life
it's true in the life of everyone
happily there is a model in progress for
how we can save work it's underway now
in Germany the German government runs a
program called kurz Arbeit that means
short time employers are encouraged not
to lay off their workers but instead
place them on reduced hours the
government then steps in to compensate
some of those missing wages to help the
companies with payroll now it may cost
taxpayers more than Romney's grand a
month program but critically it keeps
people in their jobs it's also straight
full
unlike so many of the double-secret
backward tax rebate programs the
geniuses in Congress are always coming
up with and telling you you should love
and be happy with but you don't ever
understand them another today this idea
has a clear goal and it achieves it
during the 2008 financial crisis
Germany's economy shrank by a higher
proportion than ours did in America yet
at the same time Germany's unemployment
rate actually felt labor force
participation rose so amazingly in the
middle of an economic contraction a bad
recession more people were working than
before that's the key as we look forward
to turbulent times employment stability
meaningful work if you want to help
people whether this Christ is the one
that's coming save their jobs it's that
clear